let's talk about the game on everyone's
lips on everyone's mind on everyone to
PlayStation 4 looking at bsm and
hopefully on everyone's pc come for ride
a the no man's sky yeah it's mine
actually it's your sky line oh really
yeah you got up there first that was me
we're their pre patch that was me
joining the space will talk about the
pre patch stuff later yeah but first of
all I just want to I there's a bunch of
ways you can talk about this game yes
first I just want to kind of ask are you
enjoying it like that's I think the most
important thing so here are you enjoying
the nice guy I am enjoying no man's sky
I've played about 20 hours now combined
pre-pageant post patch it is a very
interesting game that is that is very
big and so big that it's really hard to
even understand it mmm so I love the way
it plays with scale I love the way it
encourages you to seek out new
discoveries and it tempts you to gain
new wealth so you can like Gale the you
know the hot new rise and hot new
equipment yeah I mean I'm very much
enraptured in the experience right now
and I am NOT headed towards the center
of the galaxy right yeah either am i
ugly enough for different reasons yi
probably I said that's the thing I one
of the things that has been like the
sort of the curse and the blessing of
this game is that how vague they've been
about it and I think in one way it's set
expectations in a weird way for some
people where they think that maybe this
is a different type of game to what it
is but in another way it's like so much
about this game like when I when you
start the game off I was like my ships
broken I'm supposed to find Hydra blah
blah and koala blah blah and I'm like I
have no idea what any of this stuff is
yeah and like that whole experience has
been fascinating in the same way that
like playing Minecraft for the first
time we're playing Terraria for the
first time at you've played like 20
hours now does that continue that sort
of sense of discovery sense of discovery
yes but you definitely come to grips
with what you should be doing or what
you could be doing at this stage I am
NOT hello there aren't that many
surprises in terms of the bigger picture
maybe I'll find an element I hadn't seen
before right or an item I hadn't seen
but the bigger picture stuff like what
it means to travel from one solar system
to know
what it means to discover a planet you
know when you find an outpost on that
planet or an anomaly in space like what
that means and what you can gain from it
I've kind of seen all of that but all
that stuff remains interesting because
each one is like an egg and inside the
shell like a bunch of different elements
right that are different than they were
the last make you cracked yeah it's
crazy i was watching robin married to
their live stream last night and they
were bouncing from planet to planet not
finding any life whatsoever while at the
same time i was playing in a solar
system where like it was four planets
they all have teeming with life like
there's too much i was like making so
much money yeah and mike you played a
bit since its launched how are you
finding a man sky so far yeah I only I
didn't I only played about three hours I
think and I knew it was gonna be a
survival game i really like survival
games but i think with this i wasn't i
was going into it expecting more just
like exploration and so right now I've
just been figuring out you know like the
inventory and the actual survival loop
of collecting like isotopes for your
weapon or for your certain like boosters
you know collecting like actually
crafting and whatnot but so far it's
intriguing i mean the my favorite part
is like actually coming up off a planet
with no loading screen just like waiting
up at the sky and just boosting as fast
as you can going to another planet doing
the hype like the speed boost the pulse
boost i think it's called and then going
down into another planet and landing and
it's all seamless that's like incredible
that part is really gratifying for me
the survival I feel maybe like I said
the farther I get in maybe I'll actually
like start to enjoy the survival more
and kind of accept that alongside the
exploration I've been hearing that the
farther in you get the more you'll get
acclimated to the survival elements
you'll get better equipment I think I'm
assuming you figure out you start to
figure out the stuff you kind of need to
be collecting all the time yeah yeah and
you come to terms with like the the
process like the order of operations
right like before you sell anything
before you go hunting for anything make
sure all your equipment is filled with
energy right that includes your ship
like that includes you know your the
hazard protections to like everything
like take care of that first and you're
pretty much good to go and have fun but
yeah they're really going is you can
definitely find yourself in a pinch
you're like crap why did I sell that
material I need it for XYZ or I kept
landing and then cuz like your launch
thrusters
require a certain elements to launch you
can't take off the planet without it at
the start I was like terrified sit on my
ship because if I didn't land that near
it was a plutonium whatever it's called
I like I couldn't take off again now I
have like a cargo full of the [ __ ] just
to make sure because it was like so
scary to me yeah but yeah it's like that
kind of a I guess yeah you kind of you
start to get us like a sixth sense for
the stuff d the plates you need to kind
of keep spinning yeah like unless i'm
defining sentinels which get at this
point where i'm at where I'm finding
really rare materials centers or sandals
are guarding them right it feels more
like a survival game now because I'm in
current incurring damage that's really
tangible and hard to fix but I guess I
met odds with the idea that this is
mostly a survival game because I've been
on the worst planets you know that you
know just really bad ones and it doesn't
feel that threatening like yes the winds
are blowing and yes there's a lot of
radiation but like my suit can handle it
you can always just get your ship and
just drive up fly up you can always just
do that I mean that's one of the crazy
things is like an outpost on the other
side of the planet that takes longer to
get to that another planet right like
it's crazy the way scale works oh yes
space is sort of like a sanctuary in a
way where you can get out and take care
of yourself but you do start getting
attacked more Sentinel start chasing you
into space right and those pursuits are
the ones i'm finding now oh I really
feel like challenged sentinels chase you
into space so if you engage sent this
one instance that I can refer to I don't
know how it applies everyone else's
experience but I was fighting sentinels
on the ground it was like two drones
like a quadruped head mmm Sentinel I
took off in my ship but they were still
looking for me whether or not they were
looking for me was the reason this
happened Sentinel ships then started
warping into a wash I killed the ones
there and they're like well there's more
ships coming so i had to find a
different planet they didn't pursue me
down to there there wasn't I so I don't
think it's this pursuit that lasts from
ground to space but I think that was a
particularly volatile solar system so I
guess you know I feel like the the
amount of conversations were in high for
an expectation and stuff around this
game in particular of have been crazy
over the past couple of months but never
on the other side of the launch at this
is a game that was like so many were
pushing very very hard obviously you
know hello gains very small team but
they were
on the main stage of you know since the
game awards and I was III and then it
was the next III and there was a lot of
hive an expectation around around this
game do you haven't met your
expectations of what you thought this
game was it has completely and my
expectations were that this would be a
world that is bigger than I can really
get a grip on that I can seamlessly
transition from planet to outer space to
a new solar system that i will be making
discoveries and that there is a tangible
hope that one day what i do will be
noticed by somebody else or I may
encounter something that is a product
for someone else's efforts but again not
that there's guarantee just that there's
a hope that you haven't and all those
things have been fulfilled and for me
the thing that that's even more
gratifying is to discover this sort of
like mysterious story line that's kind
of happening that it's not told to you
really you kind of you see it through
the eyes of your character as they
ponder what's happening around them
because there's no common language you
know right everything you kinda just
have to suppose everything based on what
you see that has been the nice surprise
on top of the expectations that were
fulfilled for right so I feel totally
gratified I the story stuff I'm
surprised how much I really like it i
can't really in video games at least i
can't really think of another game
that's that's done it this way where
it's this it's it's so vague and so
alien like everything about this feels
it's almost like i was trying to sort of
explain it this morning and to my wife
it's almost it's almost like you're
reading an exciting pedia about a sci-fi
world like where it's like it's the
information that they're telling you is
is you don't need no one piece of it and
it's part of a much grander thing and
you can never it's like the opposite of
most video games were there like this is
the word you live in yeah these are the
rules this one it seems like you could
probably play the entire game and I
still have no idea what the goddamn
house going on it's so hard to come to
come to grips with it and you know like
you're by yourself for the most part and
like yeah you'll see trader ships in
space stations we don't really see the
traders like unless you talk to them but
even though they're not present but then
you find someone on a planet and you're
like oh thank god like another life-form
now they're like human being who's
trying to survive in this world not
human being another life-form that's
trying to survive and you get there and
you have this moment of hope until you
go talk to them and you're like
they don't know what I'm I don't know
what they're saying yeah like we can't
communicate like I feel more lonely than
ever because I can't relate to this one
thing that I found in so much time like
it's crazy how big it is but one thing
I've kind of noticed I'm following the
Atlas path right me too I think and
there's a lot of sort of like religious
allegory in there where it seems to be
asking the big questions that a lot of
us may be asked when we think about the
meaning of religion whether we're a part
of it or not and I've been on both sides
of that conversation having forced to be
grown at the Catholic and a lot of the
questions I had when I was in church
that led to my beat me being a sort of
an atheist as an adult I'm seeing those
same questions being asked up around me
in this game not with any one
perspective behind it but just the
questions are being asked it's
fascinating some uh yeah i think it's
it's it's much my expectations but I
also feel like my expectations were like
I've had a lot of access to this game
over the past couple years and I feel
like from a nerdy I I kind of knew I had
a decent idea what it was that it it
wasn't that I think there are some
people who think this is some sort of
like massive you know combat focus space
opera and it's certainly not bad yeah I
never got that I think my initial
impression when they first were like
showed at the Sony stage was it's like
elder scrolls in space rice which is
what like it's very different cuz like
Skyrim when years dense as that no like
in terms of like quests site like this
one quest right that's just like glow
Jeff what like the same well as of now
yeah like Skyrim Skyrim's is finite
thing so I took my time scouring every
inch whereas now it was so overwhelming
at first which you can imagine there's
like what 18 and a half quintillion
planets I think when the math works out
but like the fact that it might as well
be infinite for all for us we're never
going to see everything so that was
overwhelming at first I was kind of like
what's the point of this I'm never gonna
find everything but then that became
like the driving force be like this is a
curiosity incarnate like I'm just gonna
keep finding new things no matter how
long I play this game if I play this
game 25 years from now I'm gonna see new
things like but I still am at that point
where I'm wondering the survival stuff
is actually like helping because i think
my initial concern before the game
released was like how much substances
they're not planet to planet galaxy
galaxy basis but its leading me to
believe that getting there will have
those nice like satisfying
survival loop crafting loop and also
just the traveling itself is so
satisfying so I'm looking forward to
another 30 hours or so I think it is
like chill from and I haven't played
nearly as much as you Peter but from
what I've had I think it was like just
enough substance like I'd say that's the
case there's a lot of repetition in like
outside is he okay it's yeah and it's I
i was i was playing last night thinking
like i don't know why i'm not bored of
this because like a lot of it is quite
like the same thing over and over again
and you're just like saving up money to
get the new thing and then looked like I
wasn't born because the planets were
like I was just like goddess is
beautiful or like I keep getting
distracted and I'm getting distracted by
mission animations with just like I I
guess activities that on the face with
aren't like that I mean it's like okay
for instance for the past three hours
I've been trying to catalogue every
animal on this one [ __ ] clock which I
can't understand why you would want to
do that because that way off is like 300
right yeah like I can make that much
money just mining and when I started it
I I didn't realize that and I've
actually accumulated a bet that much
just by popping down to the planet over
back but I have one animal left and I
spent the past hour looking crazy
bastard egg thing sure is a real ugly
symposium from the sky can you know this
alone I've literally like gone off flown
to decide a plan has gone down I like
cuz the day-night cycles so the some
animals are only appear on one side of
the planet or different biomes on the
planet so like there's one place where
there's loads of these different planets
have different rotations right so that
cycle is gonna be long for some so like
I'm going all over the place and I've
literally like gone up and landed about
15 times looking for this one and it's
like I'm just going like nope I know and
now I know all the other animals by
heart their names so that's gonna be fun
to like go to a new planet and be like
oh who are all these strange animals i
don't know because i feel like i'm
familiar with all these other ones now
but like that sounds so boring that
sounds like the most boring thing in the
world I'm just like playing one of those
stupid Safari games to come out on like
the wii nobody buys but it's like it's
I've been doing it and enjoying it yeah
yeah
you